das ist nicht die einzige Propaganda
Lüge die aufgetischt wird teilweise sind
diese Geschichten die erzählt werden
wirklich hanebüchen wir haben mal fünf
für Sie zusammengestellt
die russische Propaganda-Maschine ri
läuft auf Hochtouren klingt erstmal nach
Profis doch anscheinend sind im Land der
Fake News ziemliche diletanten am Werk
wie hier die neueste Meisterleistung
Putin in timos und Ex-Präsident Dimitri
medwedev besucht vor kurzem die
russischen Truppen in der Region
ohrenburg dabei soll er laut der
russischen Nachrichtenagentur TAS auch
Truppenübungen beobachtet haben dazu
verbreiteten die kreml-medien dieses
Foto von Medvedev der Haken der
Vize-Chef des Sicherheitsrates konnte
gar nicht sehen die Klappen seines
Fernglases versperrten die Sicht Bild
zeigt Ihnen die Top 5 peinlichsten
propaganda-fans der Russen seit
Kriegsbeginn Platz 5 sim-kartenfail im
April sorgte dieses Foto für ordentlich
Lacher im Netz hier wurde laut Tyrann
Geheimdienst FSB ein Neonazi
festgenommen gefunden wurden unter
anderem sechs Sprengsätze 8
Molotow-Cocktails Pistolen einen Granate
mehr als 1000 Patronen Drogen und
gefälschte ukrainische Pässe doch eines
ist ziemlich auffällig auf den gut
präparierten propaganda-fotos zwischen
Hakenkreuz T-Shirt und Neonazi Literatur
lag fein drapiert drei
Erweiterungspakete des beliebten
computerspieles Sims 3 vermutlich wurde
von einem Geheimdienstler die
Einkaufsliste falsch verstanden statt
drei SIM-Karten auf Russisch trisimkie
wurden drei Computerspiele gekauft
Platz 4 peinliche propaganda-show im Mai
fuhr der Kreml mächtig auf mit einer
mega propaganda-show zum 8-jährigen
Jubiläum der Annexion der Krim im
Moskauer Olympiastadion durch Nicki
hielt Kreml Diktator Putin eine Rede
angination doch etwas lief schief die
Putin Rede wurde im TV live übertragen
als mitten im Satz die propagandaschow
ein jedes Ende fand aus dem Kreml hieß
es etwa eine halbe Stunde nach der
Unterbrechung es habe einen Serverfehler
gegeben ziemlich schnell für die
Propaganda delikanten
Platz 3 Bonnie und Clyde im Russen TV
zum jahrestag des Sieges der Sowjetunion
über Nazi Deutschland am 9 mai strahlte
der russische Sender Channel One sein
traditionelles Konzert aus aber ein Foto
zog die ganze Zeremonie ins Lächerliche
im Hintergrund der Bühne wurden alte
Schwarz-Weiß-Bilder lächelnder
russischer Paare von 1945 gezeigt
plötzlich jedoch ein Foto des
berühmtesten verbrecherpärchens der
amerikanischen Geschichte Bonnie und
Clyde Platz 2 Flugzeugträger der jüngste
Patzer in Schuman investibirien wurden
Plakate aufgehängt um den Tag der
russischen Marine zu feiern im Zentrum
eines der Plakate zu sehen ein
Flugzeugträger umrangt von russischen
marineflaggen die Überschrift alles Gute
zum Tag der Marine blöd nur dass das auf
dem Plakaten abgebildete Kriegsschiff
gar nicht von der russischen Marine ist
die dort abgebildete us-age bush ist ein
Flugzeugträger der United States Navy
und gehört somit den Amerikanern nicht
den Russen
Platz 1 Moskva gleicher Tag andere Panne
diesmal von einer russischen Zeitung in
Baschkortostan gratulierte die
Regionalzeitung ihren Lesern zum Tag der
russischen Marine und veröffentlichte
dazu auf seiner Webseite ein Foto des
Kreuzers Moskva über dem die weiß-blaue
marineflagge wehte die Überschrift heute
ist der Tag der russischen Marine
peinlich aber die Moskwa liegt auf dem
Meeresgrund Putins Flaggschiff übrigens
das größte russische Kriegsschiff seit
dem Zweiten Weltkrieg wurde von der
Ukraine am 14 April versenkt das
bestätigte an jenem Abend auch das
Verteidigungsministerium in Moskau
damals war die Zerstörung der Moskva
eine peinliche Klatsche für Putin in
seinem blutigen Überfall auf die Ukraine
[Musik]